[Music]
chuck i got a good one for you
uh-oh i'm ready it's it's a source of
no end of misconception in our world
in civilization oh so yeah yeah so it's
a big one okay
all right and it's the difference
between heat
and temperature they are not the same
thing
okay so you you have already
you you're right uh because if you say
that this
is a source of misunderstanding
then um i am the source
because guess what heat and temperature
i mean it's the same damn thing okay
all right i will start off i hate
starting off this way but i will
um i'll start off defining them from the
point of view of a physicist
okay all right all right so the
temperature
of the thing is the average
kinetic energy of its vibrating
molecules
okay all right so you have a thing
that is of a temperature you go you look
in close
all the molecules if they're atoms it
could be atomic they're all vibrating
they're riding fast dividing slowly okay
you put a thermometer in there that
vibration gets communicated to the
thermometer
the thermometer reads a temperature is
the average
kinetic energy the average energy of
motion of the vibrating particles the
average
which means a single particle has no
temperature
okay okay wait a minute a single a
single particle that's right
there's no this it doesn't meet right so
temperature is a macroscopic
thing that you obtain from a from a
from a liquid a solid a gas it doesn't
matter okay
that's temperature okay okay so you heat
it up some more you get higher
temperature oh by the way
there's a range of at which they vibrate
some vibrate slowly
some vibrate quickly it's the average
that's the temperature
uh let me say that another way at a
given temperature
uh there's a like a a the average which
is where most of them are kind of
vibrating and then there's some off at
the tail
some are vibrating slowly some are
vibrating quickly
okay okay here's an example okay let's
get
water at let's
stick to fahrenheit let's say we are
200 degrees water no
room temperature water 75 to 70 degrees
okay here you go
some of those water molecules are
vibrating very fast others very slowly
okay right some of them are vibrating
fast enough
to escape right
yes okay but it's just those only at the
at the edge did they escape
they're at the very top right at the
very top they'll escape the rest are
stuck
right okay so now they escape this is
evaporation
correct and you don't have to be boiling
water to evaporate the water
because the fastest moving molecules are
always escaping okay
that's right okay also just while we're
there
if you are a low mass atom or low mass
molecule relative to high mass
molecules your low mass winds are
vibrating even faster
on average you can split them up the
heavy ones are moving slowly
the light ones are moving quickly the
average of all of them that's the
temperature
so funny how even atoms work
kind of the way uh every molecules work
the way
we do you know that the heavy ones
kind of slow you just kind of chill
[Laughter]
and the lighter ones are
for example our atmosphere has both
oxygen and nitrogen in it
and the oxygen molecule weighs slightly
more than the nitrogen molecule
okay so on average if you separated out
the oxygen it would be
at a lower temperature than the nitrogen
but mix them together you only get one
temperature because there's a mixture
that's all i'm saying about temperature
okay okay so heat let's go to that
individual
vibrating molecule and say how much
energy you got
write down that number let's go to the
next one how much energy you got
write down that number and just keep
doing it for every molecule
every molecule in your soup so it's not
okay gotcha so so the sum
of all the kinetic energies of all the
vibrating molecules
that's how much heat is in the thing
gotcha
okay so one is an average the other is
this
the actual number the sum of all the
so your cup of coffee in the morning
at 210 degrees fahrenheit
right is hotter than the ocean
but the ocean has more heat
oh snap
it's hotter than the ocean but the ocean
because the ocean has more molecules and
you're going to
add up some you add up the sum
of all the molecules total molecules
okay
that's why your coffee cup your coffee
cup is not going to start a hurricane
right it doesn't have enough energy in
the coffee cup to make that happen
and that and that heat that is
all the energy in the ocean oh my gosh
and that's why the ocean can start a
hurricane
but your coffee can only make your
morning very bad because it's spilled in
your lap
or it can speed up your digestive tract
and
you're stuck in the car when you gotta
go
coffee has other consequences to your
life about that part
that's the last time i drink coffee and
get stuck in traffic
oh so that is a very
important so now watch what happens so
so now
we have climate change where the the
world is heating
right and you can say okay um
how much did the of the air we don't
want the air to go up by two degrees
celsius whatever because
that could trigger other changes well
let's check the ocean how much did the
ocean go
the ocean went up a fourth of a degree
or like a half a degree and you're
saying to yourself that's not much
right do you know how much total energy
that is
oh my god that is oh
my gosh okay
so chuck that's why when you're trying
to
create the energy budget of a climate
system
right there's sunlight coming in and it
warms the air
is that where all the energy goes no
no all the whole there's energy that
goes into the ocean
and it can hang out there lurking all
right
so you could you could reduce your
carbon footprint
and reduce the warming of the atmosphere
then the ocean says
i got heat i can dump into the
atmosphere and i can keep doing this
even after you have corrected your
behavior
to protect future generations and the
balance that
it's actually an imbalance at this
moment the the relationship
between the the heat that the land
retains and the atmosphere and the
oceans
the ocean winds every time right because
of it's
it's this tremendous heat reservoir
so i just wanted to distinguish the
difference
between heat and temperature and there's
one little thing you might not know
okay okay um
do you know air conditioners right it's
like it's hot outside
and it makes you cool on the inside okay
yes
okay all right do you ever ask how it
accomplishes this
um not really all i know is you just
turn it on
i just turn it on and it works and uh
from the time that i was a kid i know
that uh you don't leave the door open
because we're not trying to cool the
whole neighborhood
what the hell you think we're trying to
cool the whole neighborhood shut the
door
chuck i thought you had finished your
therapy on your childhood
experiences but apparently some sessions
remain
uh so here so what's happening there is
okay there is heat
inside of your room no matter what
temperature your room is as long as it's
above absolute zero
there is heat there heat there's a pump
that takes that heat
removes it from your air and sticks it
outside
that's why no matter the temperature
outside if you feel the air conditioner
it's hotter at the air conditioner
why is it hotter because it just pulled
that heat from your
your 72 degree room temperature room
that you're trying to keep cool
it pulled it out and it can reverse that
okay so let's reverse it it's called
reverse it's a heat pump a reverse heat
pump
in your winter okay you want it to be
warmer in your room than the outside
once you switch the heat pump your air
conditioner says
okay let me take
heat from this cold air
out there it's 40 50 degrees i don't
care let's take heat from that cold air
and put it in your room
and make your room hotter even hotter
than it would otherwise be compared to
the outside
it can do that because there is heat
there no matter what the temperature is
as long as it's above that
as long as it's above absolute zero that
is okay
it's clever engineering just think it is
brilliant
go hug hug your favorite engineer this
is where this comes from
brilliant okay so i'm gonna admit that
when we started this
i was like this guy has really dug a
hole for himself this time
no way no way this is going to be
interesting
okay but i gotta admit this is
great next time you're sipping a cup of
coffee looking out at the ocean
yeah just just think to yourself just
know that that ocean
has more heat than this hot scalding cup
of coffee you could burn yourself with
the coffee
but the hurricane won't it won't matter
to the hurricane that's right
wow that is so cool man that is cool all
right that's a quick one
you got it so chuck that was an
explainer video on heat versus
temperature
the physics and the engineering of it
all right we got to break it there
i'm neil degrasse tyson bidding you to
[Music]
keep